here to react newt gingrich former
speaker of the house and a fox news
contributor
uh i think it's obvious that biden's
numbers
newt are artificially propped up as a
result of
the checks that are flooding america uh
when do the chickens come home to roost
on his approval numbers
if this continues well first of all when
i talk to people
like john mclaughlin who's a very famous
pollster
he points out that most of the news
media over
samples democrats by about 20 percent
so you're really getting very phony
polls that make
biden look much stronger than he is i
agree with you i thought what you said
earlier
was really important i remember i was at
georgia and i taught at
west georgia college i knew jimmy carter
as governor
i ran for congress while he was
president um
there are there are weirdly similar
patterns
here you see the economy beginning to
stumble a little bit
with the jobs numbers coming in about
800
000 below what they thought you see the
beginning of real inflation
you see it compounded by just plain
incompetence i mean
it should bother every american that our
largest pipeline to the east
43 percent of all oil and gas for the
eastern united states
could be hammered by some private sector
criminal gang
and we have no idea who they are where
they are how to get them
how to make it too expensive for some
other gang to do it
these things all are compounding and i
think that uh
another couple months you're going to
see a real sense of dismay
that this is a democratic party
that is uh hanging on to power by a
very very thin i mean
i think everyone watching tonight has to
again understand
washington dc is not working now
i mean when you drive in washington
first of all it's either blocked off and
and yeah
i think it feels like an eighth of the
city is totally blocked off
people aren't back at work i don't know
if they're coming back to work
i don't know when dc is ever going to
recover even if they open it up because
they've been shamed into doing it
so they're not even working and yet
and yet they kind of glibly say oh well
it's not really a gas shortage it's not
like
the toilet paper don't hoard it like
that's going to make people feel better
when they run out of gas on the beltway
and they almost get
sideswiped by a tractor trailer are you
kidding me
look you're raising two very different
positions both of which are worth
exploring
on the first one i think the house and
senate republicans should announce
that they want to find out who was so
unessential
that they never showed up and as soon as
we get a chance to take control
those people ought to frankly be
replaced
if we don't need them don't pay them
which by the way
if you applied it to the teachers unions
would decimate
their dues paying memberships
second i think for the entire political
class
this has been a devastating year i mean
who's going to believe
governor cuomo who's going to believe
the governor of
michigan who's going to believe falci
who's had
780 positions in the last year
i think the cdc is ruining
its reputation as a serious institution
so
and of course you know joe biden
basically is humpty dumpty
he believes that he can control words he
can define words
uh and as humpty dumpty says in alice in
wonderland
it's all a question of who's in charge
you or the word
so you look at that and then you look at
his press secretary
imagine her job i mean can you imagine
trying to go in and clean up every
morning now after that mess that biden
leaves
yeah well she's leaving next year she
said but i think she has the easiest job
on earth no one even asks their tough
questions it's like they just like can
you i'll bring you cookies and then you
can enjoy the cookies the chocolate chip
cookies
and then we can all go home and it's not
a crisis and no one's gonna ask
i mean that's pretty easy job actually
when you think about it
new we got a roll thank you so much
great to see you tonight hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else